hey youtubers is Charlie so you guys
submitted a whole bunch of awesome
questions for my episode to Q&A you also
saw a whole bunch of really cool Easter
eggs that I totally missed lots of good
Danny pink and Missy theory so please
keep them coming and I'm almost done
with my move too so eventually it'll
stop looking like I'm making videos from
heaven like Missy snatched me and I'm
just uploading videos from inside
wherever heaven is well let's go ahead
and get into it careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet I'll wait just a sec okay ready
question number one action vids asks
whites in the Dalek recognize the doctor
it was all because the regeneration they
only had info up to Matt Smith there was
a little confusion because souffle girl
Clara erased all their memories of the
doctor and then they relearned about him
during the Christmas special after
assimilating Tasha LEM the Daleks do
have independent minds like the college
mutants do but they also have the
machine parts that basically upload all
their individual memories to the
collective because rusty rejoined the
Dalek fleet at the end it's possible
that he either withheld the info on the
new doctor or all the Daleks know about
him now either way I think they're
totally gonna follow up on it at some
point but on to question number two
walking who awesome name what do you
think of Danny pink story so far
I totally love him but we haven't gotten
a really good solid Danny pink episode
so I think we'll probably learn a little
bit more about his backstory and I'll
give us a better picture for what Samuel
Anderson's character that he's
developing is gonna be like I think
episode 4 is supposedly gonna add a lot
of backstory so it should get a lot more
interesting so I'll have to ask this
question again whenever we see that but
like I said in my review Sam Anderson
does a great job of going from funny to
dark in a heartbeat he's not quite as
grand as Capaldi but I think be able to
turn on a dime like that is really
important for Doctor Who stories and
really no one is expected to be as brand
as the doctor as far as new characters
go I think he's a really interesting new
flavor there'll be a few more new
characters that we haven't met yet this
series and I think they did a great job
casting them all you know whatever their
stories end up being there gonna be a
lot of fun and really interesting so I
think you guys will love it but on to
question number three tiger blood asks
do you think that rusty will be a
returning character definitely I think
that Moffat created something really
unique in this idea of a good Dalek it'd
be a real shame if he's totally wasted
it by never bringing it back
Rusty's like the new handles but I'd
really like this
though is a rusty scene several episodes
down the road where he comes back with
his own Armada like rusty started
converting other Daleks to his cause
bit by bit then he just rides in like
the cavalry with his giant fleet of good
Daleks that would be totally crazy I
really hope that he's part of the Missy
plot like whenever it comes to that
final conflict he'll show up to help the
doctor I'm always a big fan of whenever
enemies and stories are forced to work
as friends and the Daleks are the Time
Lords worst enemies unless you've
considered the Time Lords to be their
own worst enemies but on to number 4 -
viho man asks do you think that Missy
will snag everyone that dies in all the
episodes so that they can appear with
her in the final episode so she has
shown up in consecutive episodes so it
seems that way but I don't think that
she's gonna be in every single episode
and I think that she is selective about
who she picks I do think the
circumstances of a person's death is
important to whether or not she saves
them and it's still a little unclear as
to what part of each person she's
snatching like isn't the life force is
it full-on teleportation at the moment
its death or is it like a silence in the
library situation where copies of people
are being made it seems pretty clear
she's trying to win people over with
really sinister kindness she even goes
so far as to call her domain heaven via
TARDIS pocket universe wherever she is
it definitely sounds like she's got
plans for the doctor that require all
those people so here's what gets really
interesting if she wanted to kill the
doctor I don't think that she would have
called him her boyfriend remember she
also said that she wanted to keep the
Scottish accent so the real question I
think we need to ask is what does she
want to help the doctor do that requires
that army so I've already mentioned the
idea of broken promises broken trust in
series a would it be interesting if
everyone around the doctor like Clara
and all his friends broke their promises
to him but Missy who's you know kind of
looks like the villain like what if
Missy is creating this army as a way of
fulfilling a promise to the doctor which
raises a whole bunch of other questions
like what might that promise have been
that should actually be the doctors
catchphrase question like whenever he
prompts himself for a question either
way though it's pretty clear that
missing the doctor have a history
together but on to question number 5
Benjamin asks if heaven is like the
TARDIS then shouldn't the dead soldier
have been tiny when she woke up yes very
interesting Missy's garden totally looks
like a TARDIS console if it is you think
that she would have been small
she realized it around them I think
that's just more evidence that she's
only saving parts of people it's still
unclear whether it's just their
consciousness or something else like it
might be a silence in the library
situation where they're just backing
people up but she could also be stealing
their life force right now we've only
seen a couple Missy scenes so I think
we're gonna have to wait a couple more
episodes just to get some more
information but on to question number
six Alex asks do you think the Danny
pink would leave the show if Clara left
or what he stays a companion I think
that he would totally stay just because
the doctor cannot travel without a
companion but it's also possible that he
and Clara could be leaving just because
someone in the comments wrote they saw
an interview with Samuel Anderson where
he said that he's not a companion I
haven't seen it so I can't really
comment on that but I do think that
Danny pink will stay on I mean it
wouldn't be Doctor Who if he didn't have
someone to stand there and listen to him
prattle on regardless of what ends up
happening though I think all questions
are gonna be answered by the Christmas
special we don't really even have a
title for that yet last year they
actually filmed the Matt Smith special
around this time so hopefully in the
next several weeks were getting some
better information but on to question
number seven Sandrine asks do you think
that the Missy situation will trigger
darker instincts in the doctor like the
Time Lord victorious moments I do think
it'd be awesome if the Missy story led
to a big callback to that robot
conversation where he said do you have
it in you to kill me doctor like Missy
you know whoever this big person from
the doctor's past is forces him to kill
her that would be as dark as the show
could go you know all of episode 2 was
about the doctor showing himself that he
was a good Dalek and he obviously hated
that idea so he's gonna continue to
wrestle with the darkness inside I'm
heard the Dark Passenger for anyone who
also watched Dexter on Showtime I think
that a doctor who is always a showed the
kid I think Doctor Who is always a show
that gives us a certain amount of
closure so regardless of whether or not
we're crying in the finale I don't think
the doctor is gonna completely
compromise himself he's not gonna trash
his motto never cruel or cowardly never
give up never give in I think that
killing Missy would be the cowardly
thing to do in that situation
but on to question number eight Cajun
asks will souffle girl Clara turning
into a Dalek be important to anything
going on in series eight so I think
they're gonna continue to reference the
impossible girl storyline from 7b but I
think it's just going to be inside jokes
I don't think that specific version of
Clara is gonna play a critical role
regardless of which explanation you
leave right now which version of Clara
is she the copy or she the original
Clara I think they're pretty much done
with that storyline
I think anytime future episodes make
reference to other versions of car it'll
just be them referencing the old
episodes keep your eyes peeled though
because they will probably continue to
make those just as long as she's a
companion but on to question number nine
Dovahkiin asks when the doctor healed
rusty and we saw the crack in the wall
was the root cause did it have anything
to do with the Time Lords I think it was
a visual reminder for the Time Lords but
I don't think the crack specifically was
put there to make rusty break when the
doctor was showing him his memories
there were a lot of flashbacks to big
moments in Doctor Who history but I
don't think the Time Lords put the crack
in the universe they're inside rusty I
think if the time words wanted to
contact the doctor they do so in a much
more direct way it seemed like during
the Christmas special they had a certain
amount of control over where the cracks
the universe appeared if they could just
make them open at will I know Moffat
rights both Sherlock and Doctor Who in
on Sherlock during series three Benedict
Cumberbatch's character says there is no
such thing as coincidences the universe
is rarely so lazy so you could consider
that it's possible that the cracks in
the universe are somehow related to
rusty really though I think it's gonna
be a much simpler explanation
I think the complicated characters are
gonna be Missy Clara and Danny but on to
question number 10 and last one zombie
stabber asks that is an awesome name how
do Daleks reproduce so there are a
couple things they do primarily they
just clone themselves over time though
they also adjust their genetic template
as they assimilate new more advanced
beings you know they just update
themselves a little bit changing the
template was something that happened
during series 5 the new Dalek paradigm
rebooted their genetic code to the
original College mutant state they kind
of wrote those Daleks off the show so
the ones that we saw during asylum of
the Daleks as well as during the
Christmas special those are the most
current versions and I think they're
just same old Daleks that we've always
had in fact though if you consider the
novel's to be canons then the Time Lords
also reproduce in a similar
non-traditional way they use something
called a loom a device developed by
Rassilon to re-sequence old Time Lord
DNA and weave new Gallifrey ins into
existence I should actually say that's
how Gallifrey is reproduced just because
not all people on Gallifrey are Time
Lords
there is a theory that the doctor was
created from the reconstituted DNA of
the other like the mythical third being
that founded the tablet society with
Omega and Rassilon that's just a theory
but thank you everyone for submitting
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do and like I said I'm almost done
moving so you know pretty soon I'll
escape limbo and there'll be some more
color behind me here my next Doctor Who
video is gonna post Saturday morning
that'll be for my favorite fictional
characters brought to life in the show
just because they're doing a Robin Hood
episode and congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Marin attrex
you win the Amazon gift card I'll be
messaging you on your channel for
details but the next round of the
giveaway will start whenever I post my
episode 3 review I'm also doing a game
of Thrones giveaway to tonight if you
want to enter it'll start whenever I
post my telltale games Game of Thrones
explainer video tonight if you're just
finding me for the first time they'll be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there should be like a button somewhere
down below the video frame depending on
where you're watching this desktop or
mobile but right now you can catch up on
all the future episodes of Doctor Who PI
clicking here I did a video with all the
synopsises for all the episodes in
series 8 and you can click here for my
episode 2 review thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you